Political rookie Emmanuel Macron is leading
the polls and is tipped to be France's next
president.
The 39-year-old’s meteoric rise has shaken
the political establishment...
while also being its last hope.
His centrist, pro-European, open-border views
stand in stark contrast to the rising voices
of Europe's resurgent far right.
This is how Macron’s unabashed ambition
and drove him from star pupil,
to banker, to political rebel
and now to the hot favourite to lead France.
Macron was raised in the town of Amiens, two
hours north of Paris…
This is the house he grew up in.
The eldest of three children from a family
of doctors, he attended a Jesuit school.
A precocious kid, he preferred the company
of teachers to other pupils.
And it was at school that he met his future
wife.
Brigitte Auziere was coach of the drama club.
They worked closely together to re-write a
school production
He was 16.
She was 40, and married with three children
Gossip about their relationship began to spread
and Macron left Amiens to finish high school
at an elite establishment in Paris.
Auziere followed later to teach
And the pair married when Macron was 30.
After school he attended university in Paris,
studying Philosophy,
then went to the prestigious National School
of Administration, a breeding ground of the
French elite.
He works for four years as a high level bureaucrat
at the Ministry of Economy, before moving
to the renowned investment bank Rothschild.
Macron was quickly parachuted into managing
a massive acquisition
When the deal went through, he got a big payout.
Then in 2012 Macron was offered a position
working with the new president, and a personal
friend, Francois Hollande.
Two years later, Hollande gave him the prestigious
position of Minister of Economy.
He was 36.
But by now Hollande’s public approval rating
had fallen to historic lows.
Macron threw himself into a plan to loosen
economic regulation…
With testy exchanges in parliament.
But the reforms were disliked and the legislation
had to be forced through parliament, sparking
protest.
Macron increasingly criticised the government
but still enjoyed the president's support.
Then last year he launched his own political
movement, En Marche, or On the Move
thrusting him into the national spotlight.
He’s really come out of nowhere, three years
ago Emmanuel Macron was barely known to the
general public and here he is today on the verge of becoming President
That's Mark Deen
I’m the deputy bureau chief at Bloomberg News in Paris and I’m on the campaign trail with Emmanuel
Macron
The youthful contender was seen as a presidential
long shot
When he started his movement everyone, including many journalists
including myself, said oh well that's pretty cute
and it's a nice effort but he's not going to be president
But borrowing from US President Barack Obama’s
election playbook, he took to social media
and ran a large grass-roots campaign.
By the time France went to the polls for the
first round of voting in April he had successfully
reinvented himself.
He was no longer the free market reformer
working under a failed President...
but a new voice in politics.
He secured the
most votes of any candidate in the first round,
putting him into a runoff with another political
outsider,
the far-right Marine Le Pen.
Still it’s not all smooth sailing into the
The Élysée Palace -
Macron has many critics on both sides of the
political spectrum.
But against a far right candidate who wants
to leave the EU,
will voters on the left and right swing behind
Macron?
“The answer is that polls currently show
that is what will happen.
However this election is not over, abstention
is key and anything can happen,
we’ve seen it with Brexit, we’ve seen
it with Trump.